>> KAY: So, let's show you this how easy it
is to write an extension. We’re going to
build one live in front of you in the next
couple of minutes here. And it's not just
going to be a “Hello World” extension.
It's going to be something that actually does
something real. In fact, it's been a pretty
frequently requested feature in the browser
itself. We're going to build an extension
that allows you to email the page that you're
on to somebody else. So, just to show that
this is live and whatever, could somebody
give me the name of a small mammal? Anybody?
>> Gopher.
>> KAY: Gopher. Okay, a gopher. So, we're
going to name this extension a gopher. And
the way--so, what we're going to do is we're
going start by creating a manifest file.
>> BOODMAN: I think it’s spelled that way.
>> KAY: So, when we first started creating
the extension, we create a directory and we
create a file on that called the manifest
file. The manifest file is just a simple JSON
file that has some key value pairs in it.
One of them is the name. I might have a version,
a description. This is sort of the basic building
blocks sort of to find what an extension is.
For this particular extension, we're going
to use a bit of functionality called the browser
action. Now, a browser action is just a little
button that shows up in the toolbar of the
browser. And it has a whole bunch of different
options, but for now, all we're going to set
is the icon and the title of it. So, Aaron's
got an image already made that we're going
to grab for it, and the title will set something
that matches our animal here, I guess. Right.
I don't know what the sound a gopher makes.
They back, could be. So, let's go get that
image and copy it into the folder.
>> BOODMAN: Okay.
>> KAY: So, as I said, they're just collections
of Web pages and their resources, so they
just sort of live next to each other just
like they would on a Web server, but we’re
making this packet. So now, believe it or
not, we’ve got actually an extension that's
going to do something in the browser. So,
let's load it up. So, the way to do that is
we go into the browser and go to the launch
menu and extensions. So, this will take you
to the extensions management page. There's
a developer mode that you can turn on. And
from there, there's an option called load
unpacked extensions. This just says, “I'm
going to load a directory as if it were a
fully ready to go extension.” So, we load
our gopher extension and boom. Right there,
you see the new icon shows up in the toolbar
immediately, and has the little text that
he specified there. Okay. But, if he clicks
on it, it doesn't do anything. So now, it's
time to actually hook it up and make it do
something real, okay? So to do that, the next
step is to add something called the background
page. Now, background page is just an HTML
page, but it's not visible to the user. It's
hidden in the background but it's loaded when
the browser starts up and it's always running.
So, that's usually where people put the meat
of their extension launching. So, as I said,
it’s just a basic HTML page where I put
some script in there. And what the script
is going to do, it’s going to add an event
listener to the browser action button. And
that event listener is going to have a little
callback in it. And when it gets called, he's
going to call a window that open, bring up
a pop-up, and send to a Gmail URL, we’re
going to get in a minute here, and so we can
send that mail. Those of you who are Web programmers
in the audience now, there's a lot of options
to hear. So, we'll wait for Aaron to get them
all typed in?
>> BOODMAN: Yeah. Oh, yeah, I can't remember
the URLs, so I'm going to copy it someplace
else. I'm not good in remembering long random
URLs.
>> KAY: But, I am.
>> BOODMAN: So it’s easy to catch wherever
they set Webs.
>> KAY: So anyways, believe it or not, now
we’ve got an extension. We're ready to go.
So, let’s see if it actually does something.
So, the way we do this is we go to the management
page and we hit “reload,” just like you
would on a Web page. Now, a whole extension
reloads and the functionality is ready to
go. So, if you go to the Google page, we're
going to share that with somebody, click on
it. Nothing happened. Okay, live demo. So,
it's probably a bug. Let's find out, the good
thing another one...
>> BOODMAN: So unconvincing.
>> KAY: Yeah, so unconvincing. No one believes
that that was actually an accidental bug.
Okay. Well, okay. So, let's find the bug anyway.
Just play along with us here. So, when you're
doing--as I said before, you get to use all
same developer tools that you would use for
normal Web pages. And we got really powerful
once with the WebKit’s Web Inspector. You
can see the “inspect back active views”
on that page. Just click on it and brought
up the Web Inspector. The Web inspector has
a ton of powerful features. You can inspect
the DOM, manage CSS. You can look at all the
resources that this loaded. You can use the
active script debugger and set breakpoints.
You can look at the timeline if you want some
to measure performance and see what's going
where, or go to the CPU Profilers and Heap
Profilers. This is a really simple extension,
though. So, all we're going to do is notice
that there's a little red error indicator
in the corner. He is going to click on that.
And it's going to tell us what our error was.
It says that this object has no method name
to add. So, apparently we got the method name
wrong. So, let's find out what the method
name really should have been. What Aaron is
showing you here is auto-complete in a console.
The console has access to all of the objects
that are there and can show you what's there.
So, Chrome.browserx on click and it’s “add
a listener” not “add,” yeah, exactly.
So, good catch up. So for the person who caught
that in the audience and knew that we were
faking here, so, good job. So, we'll change
that to “add listener.” And now, we reload
the extension. And let's try out on that page.
There is the window. Oh...
>> BOODMAN: I forgot to...
>> KAY: Yeah, yeah. I think we forgot the
feature there, but let's add that URL back
in. Can we do that?
>> BOODMAN: Okay.
>> KAY: So, we can actually get this listener
that gets the--gets the Tab passed into it.
So, you forgot a plus there, I think.
>> BOODMAN: Oh, yeah.
>> KAY: And so, we can attach that into the
body. So it's actually going to mail the URL
to the page that we’re on. So, quick fix
that.
>> BOODMAN: Oh, I nailed it. This demo is
going awesomely.
>> KAY: Yes. Here we go. Here we go. So now
we have the working mail of this page extension.
So, we'll send it to ourselves, and then we're
done. But actually even though we got a functioning
extension, we’re not quite done yet. The
next step is we'd like to share with our friends.
So, the best way to do that is on the Chrome
Extensions gallery. So, let's go and see if
we can upload that to the gallery. So, you
hit to the developer section of the Chrome
Extensions gallery, and you say, “Add new
item.” And this guy will tell you, he wants
a Zip file. A zip, you know, just package
up the directory as a single Zip file. So,
let's just do that quickly here. And then,
upload it directly. And when that's all done,
we're going to get to set some properties
that are going--about how it's going to appear
in the gallery. But I bet a bunch of you have
already done this, so not too big of a surprise
but a short little upload. And right now,
while it’s waiting here, so it may seem
like it's taking a little bit longer than
you'd think for a small file. But it's actually
doing a little bit of work on the backend,
verifying there are no errors and checking
to make sure that things are going. So, hello,
excellent, perfect there. So now, we get to
the landing page and here is where you can
add a little more detail about what's going
to show up in the landing page when people
find your extension in the gallery. So, a
detailed description links to your Website.
You can upload screenshots linked to YouTube
videos, so that people can see screen casts
of your extension in action. We think this
is going to be a really compelling feature
and we'll show you a little bit more of that
in action later. So then when we're done,
we publish the extension and it will take
a second as it's going through. And there
you go, the extension is now live in the gallery,
and we're done. So, live extension, less than
five minutes, I think. And, well, all in all
pretty easy and pretty fast.